by Panther it's a world leader that's a  responsibility that other superheroes  don't commonly have that he has to look  out for an entire nation that will only  be the conquered and conquer the door  mulashi are women who ledged their lives  to the throne and to the security of the  kingdom  my character Okoye is the general of the  armed forces as a whole Okoye represents  the old guard and tradition while my  character and the kia two challenges  traditionally you get to decide what  kind of King you are going to me Nakia  was born to be a warrior she was born  with a warrior spirit I got into a  disagreement made a bit of a mess  jenny was very very interesting the  doora have a way of fighting that was  supposed to be inspired by moving as one  the door worked together to take down  somebody like the fight we have of  [Music]  actions there is not your typical film  raw it's real  don't please  you